Rory what inspired you to start your own
production company well I was working at
NASCAR at the time
and
I just wanted to kind of have more
control over my own destiny and make
more decisions Beyond just the creative
like control not just what I did but
like how it was done because working at
a company you know sometimes you're at
the mercy of other people's rules and
and things like that so
um I remember I went to the accounting
department at NASCAR because they would
never let us do the budgets and I really
wanted to know how budgets worked so I I
asked one of the accountants to show me
how they did a budget and
um I actually spent like a year there
kind of trying to brace myself to leave
so that I could learn different things
like how do you get your own health
insurance and and different things like
that so
um and then when I left I kind of had
two projects waiting to work on so I I
felt like I had a little bit of a
cushion of course immediately they went
away right when I left but uh it worked
out I remember being literally in my
office at NASCAR in the fetal position
like literally like in the fetal
position thinking I made this horrible
mistake but
I don't know I mean I think uh
you know that's what courage is right
you're you're your YouTube channels film
courage encourages being afraid but
moving forward anyway
right and and so we'll get into more
because I I love the story it sounds
like it was a real roller coaster ride
and it did work out it sounds like
definitely how did you know you had
everything you needed to really make
that leap you've been transitioning out
it sounds like planning it for a year
well everything runs its course
eventually so I was at NASCAR before
that I started the NFL my boss at the
NFL the head of production there went to
NASCAR and he asked if I wanted to come
with him and at the time I was like 25
years old so you know I don't have
children at that point so there's really
nothing to lose I wasn't a Nascar fan
per se but I got a lot of opportunities
there it was at a time when NASCAR was
probably at its peak of popularity Dale
Earnhardt had just died and so there's a
lot of interest in the sport and I got
to work on these awesome
uh projects there but I could see that
things were kind of going on the the
down slope so and I wanted to do other
things too I'd been there for
eight years and
this is this is a good point to have to
production it changed like when I got
out of college the idea of having my own
production company seemed like pie in
the sky because it would be so expensive
and Avid editing machine was like sixty
thousand dollars but by the time I left
NASCAR you could get Final Cut for like
20 bucks a month or something so things
had changed cameras had been become much
more inexpensive and it just became much
more user friendly for people to do
things I mean not even close to what it
is now uh but back then it just seemed
feasible if you were could plan it out
can you tell us about the day that you
started your production company actually
like the money went into your account
and what happened after that yes so I
was doing things with ESPN when I was at
NASCAR and I met the people uh that were
doing 30 for 30 and we got along really
well
so I was setting up a project about the
Manning family
um specifically Archie Manning and and
ESPN was really excited about it we got
the okay
um
and I even started I gave my notice to I
gave my notice to my previous job at
NASCAR started going out doing
interviews and all that and then I got a
call
from Archie Manning
and he's like uh Hey core he thought my
name was Corey for like multiple years
um and he's like thought it over and I
just I just just can't do it it's just
not the right time that's what he said
and he's like uh Peyton Mann Peyton his
son had a neck injury and was coming
back and he's like it's just just not a
good time and I even said to him I was
like you know uh I quit my job like hey
um to work on this and please and he's
like well you know we can revisit it in
a few months but just can't do it now
and that was that so I was uh
crushed you know I was like I don't even
know what to do because they had put in
half the budget in my bank account
so I called uh this guy at ESPN John
doll he ran 30 for 30. told him what
happened and he and he was very calm
about it he's probably much more used to
these things happening than I was at the
time and he said
uh that's fine let's just revisit it in
a few months say meanwhile I have
another project if you're interested in
it about a tornado that hit Atlanta
during a basketball game and I told him
I was like dude I'll work on anything if
you want to do the history of boogers I
don't care what it is you tell me what
you want to do and I'm I'm I just need
to get paid so I'm always eternally
grateful that he gave me this other
project to work on and then a few months
later I mean really not that much
because I remember it was actually
Mother's Day weekend when he told me
Archie told me this and by August uh I
had sent an email to Olivia
Peyton and Eli's mom Archie called me
and he said let's try it it was only
like three months later so timing's
everything and it worked out thankfully
when you talked about
how
Bridges and I know that's hard in the
entertainment industry because people
can become very fickle for reasons that
you don't know behind the scenes and
they won't tell you so so how did that
lesson that sounds like you're one of
your first lessons or you had already
learned that about keeping people in
your in your good grace despite what
happens well relationships are
everything I mean I actually think
that's
the most important there's one lesson to
take away in any type of creative
Endeavor is relationships are everything
and you know people are like I've heard
well filmmaking or the film industry is
a lot of nepotism or or political people
hire their friends it's like yeah of
course like of course you I hear friends
you want to hire people you can trust
and so uh that's true in every aspect of
production I've done with who I work
with is relationships so
while I was disappointed I did I did
know that
um timing is important I had I've had
other big disappointments I worked on
really big projects at NASCAR with big
names that we could get into
um
so I I've had had and they fell through
and there were like bumpy rides along
the way and I was removed from projects
and then back on so
I think I knew at that point that you
know things happen when they're meant to
happen and even though it can seem like
a crushing disappointment at the time
you just have to kind of keep the faith
that things will work out
so when Archie said check back with me
you you took that in good faith and you
did check back with him yes I emailed
his wife so I had her email and I was
talking to their other son uh Cooper
Manning uh you know persistence is a big
part of it it's a fine line between
being persistent and being annoying so I
try not to be annoying but I try to stay
persistent
and uh sometimes no just means no for
now and people have
things in their life going on I mean
everybody has bad days and sometimes
things seem like the world is falling
and the next day everything seems like
ah it's not so bad so I try to keep that
keep that in mind and I I felt like a
big sense of relief because uh
ESPN just gave me this other opportunity
also coincidentally I I called NASCAR
back
because I was supposed to have my last
day there and there was like a new
regime change and the boss there this
guy Eric Nyquist he still runs NASCAR
he's a great guy I just told him what
was going on I was like hey I I needed
to keep my health insurance and I said
hey if you want I'll stick around till
the end of the summer to just kind of
help with the transition of regimes and
things and
um he was like sure so I'm I'm grateful
for that yeah I'm thinking back to
something that you asked about
um what was the motivation to leave
NASCAR it what I can remember
specifically is they made me middle
management like so I was like a manager
of a department but I didn't really have
that much control like have like maybe
10 people I think my title is senior
coordinating producer or something and I
just did not want that as my future I
could see getting it's almost like a
silk coffin where you have a nice job at
the time you know 30 years old you can
be making a decent salary you have young
children but I've seen people get
trapped and then 10 years 15 years down
the line
they're just they feel stuck and I
didn't want that to happen to me if I
was gonna fail I wanted to fail on my
own accord and fail big you know if I'm
gonna fail I'm gonna fail like making a
huge disaster versus just kind of like
these micro little failures that you can
do when you're at a job
and so did you have a moment where it
was like a weekend and you envisioned
what your life could be if you stayed
well yeah you know what I did is I saw a
friend of mine get let go and Human
Resources came to his office made him
pack up all his things
supervised him and this was a guy who
was very loyal to the company and I just
saw the way he got treated so it's
almost like when you're at a company
it's a false sense of security you're
getting a bi-weekly paycheck and but at
the end of the day it's a corporation
and
it's a lot of times lip service whether
they actually care about you or not and
sometimes they have to do budget cuts
it's just part of uh life you know I
mean you see it now all the time just
read about Disney plus having budget
cuts so
um
yeah I just did not want that to be me I
did not want to get that that escort out
of the building uh so you know some
people are doing everything they could
to stay at the company I was doing
everything I could to leave the company
and I think also too the people the boss
is there I mentioned this guy Eric
Nyquist who's still there I still talk
to him he runs NASCAR he's got a great
job I think people respect respect that
you are willing to go out on your own
and give it a go I think um
I've only gotten positive feedback from
that